hello everyone uh welcome to our webinar
today thank you for taking the time out
of your day to be here
we will be discussing the challenges of
high-speed imaging
and how we address them with the
kinetics scmos camera
to take you through it we have myself
ratchet mohindra
i am a product manager at telling
photometrics
and have been so for over 10 years now
with experience with uh ccd cameras
bmccd cameras and scientific cmos and
the back illuminated scientific cmos
devices as well
we also have with us dr dan croucher dan
would you like to introduce yourself
hi yeah thanks ratchet i'm dan i'm the
marketing manager for advanced
microscopy here at teleline photometrics
where i've been for about four years now
in my role i'm mostly working with
scientists directly to to better
understand their applications
and to find out where as scientific
camera manufacturers
we can make their jobs easier or improve
their imaging performance
a little bit about teledyne photometrics
we design and manufacture
high-end cameras for low-light
biological imaging
and have been a market leader for
scientific cmos technology
for quite a few years now we were the
first company to introduce
a back illuminated cmos camera to the
market the prime95b
in terms of history we've been around
since 1978
and joined the teledyne imaging group in
early 2019
so when it comes to high-speed imaging
uh scientific cameras are
fast you could say right a typical scmos
camera as we've all
kind of come to expect is a 4 megapixel
device
that does about a 100 frames per second
and yet when i've gone out to talk to
scientists people who do imaging
users i i'm getting asked quite a lot
actually
uh is it possible to go faster
and the answer is normally something
along the lines of yes
but this is sort of the the trade-off
that you need to make
and there there's quite a few questions
you have to ask
when you want to determine are you able
to image faster
things like you know first simply how
fast would you like to image
and can you even image that quickly some
of these things
are dependent on you know the sample
that you're imaging what your photon
budget is
how much signal do you have or even how
much signal
do you need to be able to achieve you
know the appropriate signal to noise
ratio or the quality of image that
you are you're trying to trying to get
to
um how many images can you image at a
time
and and you know this starts to lend
your
lend lead you towards the idea of
there's
certain parameters and certain axes of
performance that are
really important to be able to truly
achieve
uh this this um
ability to to image at high speed and
the thing about
scientific cameras is that they sort of
require you to prioritize what you need
uh
to be able to make the trade-off in
terms of
how many samples or cells do i want to
be able to see in a single frame
because i'm normally reducing the size
of this frame
so that i can get to the frame rate that
i want
and you're constantly performing this
bouncing act
you know going to extremes at times
to only seeing you know parts of the the
sample or cell that you're trying to
image
just to be able to capture those those
dynamic events
and so we we sort of set ourselves a
challenge
um basically
how do we make the fastest camera and
it's sort of uh it's sort of an
interesting question because
people can define speed in different
ways
uh straight frame rate right purely
frames per second
determines how fast my cameras for
some users the inter frame time the time
between frames is the critical piece
you know i want uh sub sub
sub microsecond time resolution between
two events so that i can determine
what happened exactly when or the cycle
time or data points per cycle
so we define speed as being able to
collect
as much data in a single image as fast
as possible
and when we said it that way it kind of
laid the challenge
out to us quite simply right and from
then on our goal was
how do we make the fastest scientific
camera
and and this led us to the idea of
well we needed a large sensor
right because we didn't want to trade
off the area when we needed
the real the the the higher frame rates
uh and to kind of put this into context
of
why area as well as frame rate are sort
of
interrelated uh going back to the
typical
cmos camera 4 megapixels 100 frames per
second
now let's say we take that 4 megapixel
sensor and we double its size and it's
now an
8 megapixel sensor let's just say we've
doubled the number of uh
of rows just keep it simple now your
frame rate
if you kept everything the same speed
instead of going 100 frames per second
you're going 50 frames per second
because you have twice as much data but
the sensor itself
is running at the same speed so if you
double the number of rows
you also have to double the frame rate
but
by doing that you're now an 8 megapixel
sensor
that goes 100 frames per second uh have
you actually improved the frame rate
uh only if you compared to the the
original right but
what people want to be able to do is use
this whole sensor
at the at frame rates that are higher
than what they were previously able to
previously able to achieve so what they
would want is
this 8 megapixel sensor doing
more than 100 frames per second
but there's other challenges that come
with this too
you need to be able to see what you're
trying to image the faster you go
there's a proportional reduction in
the the amount of light you're able to
collect per frame
not only that you need to be able to
image
well it must look good you need to be
able to maintain this
highly large sensor with the speed
with high sensitivity but then you also
need to have
an appropriate resolution right emc ccds
uh in previous days had huge pixels
and that was acceptable because it
allowed you to see what you wanted to
but and image at a high enough rate but
you were almost always sub-sampling the
the object you were trying to to image
and we wanted to ensure that you had
this balance of being able to collect as
much light
while also being able to resolve and see
the finer details of the the samples
you're you're looking at
and and so it it leads you to
a pretty you know that's why we called
it a challenge a pretty demanding
requirement of
what we needed was a really large
imaging area
and this large imaging area needed to
have a frame rate that was
faster than what we were already able to
deliver
it needed to be sensitive and it needed
to have high resolution
and so we spent quite a few years on
this
challenge and where it led us to was the
kinetic scientific cmos camera
now in yellow here you have that typical
sc must device the four megapixels
running at 100 frames per second
and with the kinetics you get a 10
megapixel
uh roughly a hair over 3k by 3k
device with the six and a half micron
pixels sort of this optimal
size that that's worked quite well for
low light imaging while balancing the
need for
for resolution and we've we've
developed this this 10 megapixel uh
camera in a one-to-one imaging ratio
just because it
allows you to capture more of the
imaging area
and we've been able to do this extremely
large sensor with lots of
pixels and we've been able to get it to
run at
500 frames per second and to give you an
idea
uh kind of how these the speeds and
sizes of the sensors have changed over
time starting off with
a typical emcc 512 by 512
uh 16 micron pixels running at 67 frames
per second was sort of
at the time pinnacle of high speed
imaging where you had the sensitivity
you had
what you could call resolution and and
frame rate
which then took you to the typical cmos
device which we have now
um sort of surpassed again with the
kinetics
where we've gone to a
a larger area that runs five times
faster
and an area that is you know about two a
hair under
two and a half times larger so that
would mean that you would get
uh you know conservatively two times
more
uh samples in a single frame
while being able to maintain the
the high speed imaging capability of
being able to see
those extremely dynamic events this is
this is not even considering
the potential of being able to then
further region down
this large sensor to go significantly
faster than just
500 500 frames per second now
having a large sensor in a one by one
format that you know captures
a large amount of the the available feel
of few
we found that it's perfect for large
samples as well
uh allowing you to take you know less
images at a time
to to be able to capture the whole image
uh and i think
that outside of being able to just
simply
capture more dynamic events you're also
now able to cap your
you you have to take less captures to be
able to capture
or image as many objects as you wanted
to before
to give you an idea of how these these
diagonals or the areas of the sensors
have changed over time as well
uh the the typical a cmos camera has a
diagonal
a field of view of roughly 19
millimeters
and we've now increased that to 29 or
just you know just under 30 millimeters
with the with the kinetics
camera now for the
for scientific cameras there's always
inevitably
some performance trade-off and we wanted
to
architect the kinetics in a way where
this trade-off is
minimized as much as possible and so
what we we ensured that there were three
modes
that a person could use when using the
kinetics camera
each optimized for a specific use case
we have the dynamic range mode you know
sort of the name speaking for itself
it's the mode with the highest full well
capacity where it's able to detect high
and low signals
in one image now the trade-off that i
was
referencing was simply typically the
more
bit depth you have the larger the
trade-off in
frame rate you have to experience and so
we wanted to ensure that even with this
10 megapixel sensor
if there was a need for a high full wall
capacity a lot of dynamic range in your
imaging
you had the option the slide trade off
there being that
it runs at about 83 frames per second
now
keep in mind that this 83 frames per
second is at that
full 10 megapixels of of um
of sensor size and it goes back to the
challenge of
you know the more the larger the sensor
the more the increase in speed
there has to be to be able to to keep up
uh giving you the you know your your
expected high levels of frame rate
the second mode is the sensitivity mode
and this is simply the highest
sensitivity mode it has the lowest read
noise
and allows you to push the limits of
detection and this mode runs at
88 frames per second and then lastly
the the mode that we'd really designed
the kinetics camera for
is the speed mode again speaks for
itself in terms of its name
uh and it's the mode with the fastest
speed
now it is also an 8-bit mode
and one of the reasons that we went with
an 8-bit implementation
is that it allows you to half the data
storage
and this goes to how microsoft windows
handles data
when you have an 8-bit image it gets
stored as one byte
if you have a 9-bit image it will get
stored as 2 bytes or
you know 16 bits worth of data and
by by allowing our design team to go to
this
8-bit image
it's allowed us to ensure that we can
get all of this data out of the camera
into into the the computer uh
the 500 frames per second at 10
megapixels
uh at 8 bits is generating about
five gigabytes of data per second
and if that it had been if that had been
nine bits
that would have been 10 gigabytes of
data per second even
from that you know one extra bit and and
challenging it really pushes the limits
of the computer system already as an
8-bit image
and and adding that one extra bit would
make it almost
untenable in terms of in terms of being
able to
to handle and process that data now
in terms of comparing these speeds uh
the sort of baseline like we've kept
mentioning is this typical a cmos camera
and so typical of cmos camera at its
four megapixels
is running 100 frames per second and if
you took the kinetics and took it down
to the same number of rows or the same
array size
you'd see that we would run at 130. it's
about a 30 percent improvement there
similarly with the sensitivity mode
if you compared a camera to uh if you
compare the kinetics to a camera that
has
one of these uh lower read noise modes
uh for example on our prime bsi camera
we have a one electron read noise mode
that runs
43 frames per second the kinetics
in that same sensitivity mode runs 138
a significant improvement in the in the
low noise high sensitivity
um imaging mode and then finally
we have the speed mode this is where
if you look at you know emc cds and
typical scmos devices
uh the kinetics sort of is five times
faster than
a typical a cmos device not even
counting the fact that it's
uh you know two and a half times larger
in terms of
area or number of pixels you know 4
megapixels
to to 10 megapixels and that sort of
leads you to this question of
how am i then supposed to properly
compare
uh different technologies or different
cameras that have different array sizes
is should i just simply do it off of
frames per second
and now you know that's always an option
but one of the
one one of the calculations or or specs
that we
started using internally was this idea
of megapixels per second
where you're considering the total
amount of data that a camera is able to
generate
and acquire for you and and when you
look at
this megapixels per second and compared
to
you know a typical sc must device you
can see that the
kinetics cameras in all three modes and
especially the speed mode
have a significant advantage in terms of
the amount of data that they're able to
collect
going back to what i said with regards
to
it needs to still be sensitive because
you're getting this proportional
reduction in frames per second
uh the kinetics camera is a back
illuminated sensor
so it does provide you with the highest
levels of sensitivity getting
you you know as close to perfect as
possible within the visible range
with a peak sensitivity of um 95
and and you know the advantage of this
is that simply it allows you to connect
to collect as many photons as possible
in a given amount of time
and you know the the immediate advantage
there is simply
it allows you to go faster because
you're able to collect as much of the
light there is as possible
but it also allows you in in certain
situations where speed might not be as
critical
to potentially reduce the photo toxicity
by lowering your exposure times lowering
the amount of
excitation that a sample has to endure
to be able to collect your images at
high levels of signal to noise and so
with the kinetics we feel like
we really have
pushed to remove as much compromise as
possible to give you
as much performance in a single device
as possible
where you have a large field of view
which allows you to image
large samples to get higher throughput
to
to and i think dan will discuss this
later to be able to do
multi-channel imaging with significantly
larger
areas to to each channel the kinetics
with this extreme speed
it allows you to optimize your
acquisitions with the eight bits of the
mode
uh and and well also
to then deal with five gigabytes per
second
and the three modes of the camera really
allow you to optimize which
mode makes most sense for your
you know given imaging requirements at
that time
so we feel we really feel like the with
the challenges that high speed imaging
pose just in terms of being able to push
the technology
to to achieve um
this this sort of uh really high level
of performance we feel that the kinetics
has really done that and to take you
through the kinetic sort of in a
you know outside of just powerpoint
slides
uh we're going to take you through a
live demo of the product as well
uh the the camera will be run uh by
dan uh who's in our birmingham office
and i will
narrate kind of taking you through the
features and capabilities of the
kinetics camera
thanks ratchet hi everyone i'm dan and
i'm going to use the microscope now here
with the kinetics
to show you the capabilities of the
camera live
so to start with we'll be using
micromanager as our image acquisition
software
for those of you unfamiliar with it this
is a free software capable of
controlling almost all cameras and other
microscope equipment
and it's what we're going to be showing
the kinetics in today for a brief
introduction
you can see how we can go live on the
sample here and how we can take single
images snap
or album and you can see here
where we set our exposure time and you
can see here on the right the settings
that we've chosen
to use with our light source and our
camera so we've got a few different
choices
of wavelength and we're able to choose
the the different modes on the kinetics
here so just to check everything is
working let's go live
and here we have a really nice beautiful
image of our
fixed sample slide with a 60x oil
objective and we're getting the full
field of view of the kinetics which you
can see up here it's 3200 by 3200 so
that's the full
29.4 millimeters and you can see the
speed readout here on the bottom going
50 frames per second
of course because we set a 20
millisecond exposure time
so i'm going to hand back over to
ratchet now who's going to talk you
through what we're doing here while i
control the system
thanks dan so what we have here is a
great looking image uh but what we want
to be able to do
is to put this image which is using this
large field of view into a context
that's easy to understand right
in terms of the applications where
this field of view is actually quite
useful so for example
if we take cell counting as i'm speaking
dan
is switching to a 10x objective where we
will take a look at some
dappy state nuclei and we'll see how
many of them that were able to fit into
a single field of few
but to give this some context we want to
be able to compare the fields of view
to the main imaging technologies that
are currently being used
and so it's still very common today to
find ccds being used in labs
lots of companies still sell them today
including our own
and one of the most common sensors that
was used was the
sony icx-285 it also had a 6.45 micron
pixel
and was 1.4 megapixels and so
what we can do is we can apply a region
to the kinetics
camera to show what the effective field
of view of a ccd would be
and what you end up with is this 11
millimeter diagonal
now ccds are great cameras but it's it's
pretty easy to see that the size of the
sensor
is limiting us here right we're not
seeing the whole sample we're not
uh being able to image as much of the
microscope as
possible so seven to eight years ago
uh might be a little bit longer now
scientific cmos
uh was released and announced and was
available to
to users which gave us a much larger
field of view
2k by 2k which is which is great it was
an 18 millimeter field of view
but the camera was still limiting us
when we're choosing cameras and trying
to match our optics we're usually
focusing on getting the best resolution
matching nyquist
so that our camera doesn't limit what
the microscope is allowing us to image
but for field of view we've not
necessarily been able to do that the
camera has
always been the limit and at the moment
we're only getting 18 millimeters of
that field of fuel
so while we can match our resolution we
can't necessarily get
all of the information that might be
available
whereas now with the kinetics we can go
out to the full
3200 by 3200 pixels
which gives us the full field of view
this field of view here of 29
millimeters
so we're capturing all of the
information the microscope is giving us
and this is this is pretty fantastic
but why do we want this big field of
view
and what does it give us and so that's
where
one of the main advantages you know is
the ability to capture
large amounts of information to maximize
that throughput
for applications like high content
screening or
light sheet or any application where
we're dealing with
large tissue sections or large samples
that we're tiling and stitching
the key point is if you can get more
information per frame
more data points we're able to get more
information at once
and so here we can count the number of
cells available in each of these
fields of few so as dan goes through
these uh thresholding steps he takes
that first ccd image
labels at ccd as you saw um adjust the
threshold so that we can appropriately
count the number of nuclei
that he has in a single frame and what
he'll do is he will then add that to
a measurement table that will show you
at the end
he'll repeat these steps uh with the
scbos image here
which you know as he runs this cell
counting
uh plug-in that we have labels the image
scmos
uh representing you know the typical uh
two megapixel of sorry
two four megapixel 2k by 2k scmos
applying thresholds doing the
measurements and then finally switching
to
the kinetics image uh running that same
plug-in to do the counting
uh calling it the kinetics just so that
we're not confused
and applying the threshold so that we
can count the number of available uh
nuclei in the image and so as you can
see with the ccd camera we had
63 nuclei in an image with the
sc moss that went up to 178 as you'd
expect with the larger sensor
but then that again uh more than doubles
with the with the kinetics camera up to
380
nuclei in a single image you know that
is a
big improvement in terms of the amount
of data that you're able to get
in a single acquisition from the camera
now the other side of large fields of
view is people looking at
really large samples we've got a piece
of plant root here
that we we acquired with a 10x objective
and on a typical cmos we're not able to
see the full samples we're not getting
everything that this 10x objective is
giving us
and with the kinetics we're actually
able to see
the whole sample which makes the
acquisition
much easier uh you know much more
convenient
and it it really allows us to to
simplify that
now the other advantage of a very large
sample is if you want to do
multi-channel imaging
uh for example um you know dappy fitsy
texas red and then a bright field image
or a
you know another wavelength that you
might want to imagine well
as well now there's a number of ways
that we're able to do this
uh you could use a filter wheel you can
take
uh you know and then sequentially do
your acquisitions
take the dappy then the fifth c then the
text is shred sequentially
the problem with that is that if we're
looking at moving objects
uh we've got the time shift between
frames we
might miss out on information or we're
not going to be able to do the
localization between
frames because something might have
shifted
so what people want to do is to take a
single camera like the kinetics
and split the frame into four channels
to then
overlay them and you can do that with a
four-way splitter like the multi-split
from cairn and as you can see what we
have here
is we have the dappy channel on the top
left
the fit c on the top right and texas
right on the bottom left
and then at the moment we've got a black
image on the bottom right but
you know that could be that fourth
channel that you're trying to image
and each of these regions is 1600 by
1600 pixels
we're still getting a very large field
of view
about a 15 millimeter diagonal in each
one of these
and maintaining that field of view we
can do four channels
simultaneously with one data channel
going into the computer
you know and you minimize any alignment
issues
or other hassles that you might have
and as you can see it's quite easy to
then
break these images apart and overlay
them on top of each other
are giving you you know a great looking
image as well
what some people prefer to do is to use
a multi-splitter device
where they're projecting these four
channels onto
you know four different cameras for
example but there's
there's generally quite a lot of
challenges that can that can appear
there
uh you have to synchronize those cameras
together you have to make sure that the
triggering setup is done
correctly you run into issues of
rotation or alignment and on top of that
what you have is
four cameras worth of data streams going
into the computer
and you know working with that can be
can be challenging
the next thing that we'll be taking a
look at is the kinetic
speed capabilities the the frame rates
that it's able to achieve
um and so what we want to do is compare
two current cameras right and so
current typical cmos cameras are able to
go at 100 frames per second with
4.2 million pixels which is which is
pretty good
but for the users and people that really
care about the speed people that are
doing
things like uh single molecule tracking
calcium sparks or calcium imaging or uh
using voltage sensitive dyes or doing
optical mapping for those sorts of
applications
they generally want to go much much
faster
and so what we'll start off with is
uh we'll be looking at these beads here
that are currently
diffusing in in some liquid in a dish
and
what we will be doing is looking at them
in a field of view that is comparable to
these typical scmos devices
and so if we go to the one millisecond
exposure
just to make sure that we're not
exposure time limited on our frame rates
on the kinetics uh what you'll see is
that we're going at about
780 frames per second so we
are over seven times faster than the
existing technologies
right and so you're seeing this running
live looking at these beads
at 780 frames per second
but beyond this uh people especially the
people doing calcium and voltage imaging
they want to image or you know record
their data at
one kilohertz or a thousand frames per
second
and so on the kinetics what we can do is
we can put a region of
1580 by 1580 uh pixels
so that now uh we're able to go at this
1000 frames per second and as dan just
you know
adjusts the contrast there so that we
can see these beads uh what you can see
is that that frame rate is just uh just
a hair over 1000 frames per second
um and that's pretty you know
that that's pretty great uh considering
we're imaging here at a
15 millimeter diagonal now
the final thing that we want to look at
is for for people that want to go
very fast you know even faster than this
and what people are used to when it
comes to
emccds for example or other technologies
where you have to sacrifice your field
of view
to go that much faster
one of the regions or sort of a very
common region
size that they're comfortable using is
512 by 512 pixels
and so it sort of makes sense to compare
to that size
if we take that emccd for example if you
were at this 512 by 512 region
you would be imaging at somewhere
between 55 to 70 frames per second
if you take that same 512 by five total
region on the kinetics
you'll see that we actually end up at as
soon as then adjust that exposure time
at over 3000 frames per second
um you know which is pretty
fantastic considering that you know
we're able to
image at this ridiculously high speed
and do it with you know 95 percent
quantum efficiency with a sensitivity
that lets you capture and acquire the
data that you would like to
at that very high speed and keep in mind
that at the same
region size a typical cmos camera is
giving you about
400 frames per second or so
so the final thing that we want to take
a look at is on
the sensitivity side of things we have a
good range of cameras here at teledyne
photometrics for sensitivity
uh we have the prime95b the prime bsi
that offer
you know 95 quantum efficiency
but there's often also a requirement for
speed
and the thing to note is that typically
when there's speed
there's a compromise that comes into
play with regards to the read noise
for example the 8-bit mode on the
kinetics has about a 2-electron read
noise
so for the really lowest of light
techniques
single molecule imaging people using our
cameras for spinning disk imaging or on
turf systems
even white field systems where
researchers want to drive down the
exposure time to minimize photo damage
or photo toxicity
read noise can become very important in
these situations
what we've done with the prime bsi was
uh or or our other as cmos devices was
we implemented a mode
called correlated multi-sampling or cms
mode where we are able to drive down
our read noise to close to one electron
which makes it ideal for low light
techniques
and so people using our cameras on wide
field systems spinning discs or with
single molecules
really prefer to use this cms correlated
multi-sampling mode
the the downside is that this mode
requires
a compromise it requires you to run at a
lower frame rate and uh
and this is a trade-off that that that's
not just on our cameras
on all cameras there's typically this
trade-off of
giving up the ability to image at higher
speeds
to to do it at a at a lower at a lower
rate noise
but with the kinetics we've implemented
a sensitivity mode where that trade-off
is isn't isn't there and so if we take a
look at this
4 megapixel 2k by 2k region where we
have a 18 to 19 millimeter
diagonal other cameras where they might
be going at
20 frames per second 40 frames per
second the kinetics is able to
achieve frame rates of 140 frames per
second
with that same low noise performance
now the the other advantage though that
then the kinetic still
offers you is you can go to the larger
areas you can switch to a
22 millimeter diagonal right the the 22
millimeter diagonal
is the field of view that the majority
of microscopes on the market are able to
image
and at this full 22 millimeter field of
view
we're able to give you 120 frames per
second
you know with a close to one electron
read noise 95
quantum efficiency
furthermore uh because the sensor is so
large
you're able to go to a 25 millimeter
field of view as well
which some microscopes are able to
achieve
and at this full 25 millimeter field of
view we're getting
over 100 frames per second you know the
the advantage of
being able to maximize the sensitivity
without that trade-off of speed
is is is key and and finally
if we go to the full field of view of
the kinetics camera the full
3200 by 3200 pixel array you know just a
hair over
10 megapixels uh to take advantage of
that
full field of view you know with that
great sensitivity
we're still at you know about 88 89
frames per second and
so to to summarize with the kinetics you
know this is a camera that
what we wanted to do was you know have
have a camera that could take you know
as much information in a single frame
as fast as possible you know remove all
of these compromises remove the
the need to prioritize as much as
possible and and with the kinetics
we feel like we we've achieved that you
know we're able to give you
the full field of view of a microscope
and we can do it with great image
quality at
unmatched speeds and you know it it's a
camera that we're
extremely proud of and and from here
what i'd like to do is
hand it over to dan actually to take you
through
some more of the applications where we
think that the kinetics is
extremely suited for so you know thank
you for
for listening to me and uh dan take it
away
thanks ratchet so in this final section
of our webinar
i'm going to talk a little bit about the
types of scientific applications we've
been seeing where speed is an important
concern
or the types of applications we've found
that people have been really interested
in the kinetics for
and i'm hoping that what you'll get out
of it is an appreciation for the
different ways some researchers define
speed in their imaging
and show you some of the different ways
that a high-speed scientific camera like
the kinetics
addresses those challenges so uh so one
of the first
things that i want to say is that we've
we've found people doing high-speed
imaging
in so many applications and using a
multitude of imaging techniques
high speed imaging isn't restricted to a
select few
high-speed applications you find
implementations of it
everywhere from microfluidics to
spinning disk confocal to
single molecule imaging there are
examples everywhere
so what i'm going to do is break it down
to three specific application areas
that use speed in different ways to
achieve their imaging goals to hopefully
illustrate the different types of speed
there are
so the first of these i want to talk
about is calcium and voltage imaging
and that's because this is a great
example of an application
that focuses on pure speed or high frame
rate recording
now um so i'm going to give a brief
introduction to it as i will for the
other applications too
um but the calcium voltage imaging is
typically used in
neuronal cardiac or skeletal muscle
cells to investigate
action potentials calcium sparks or
calcium transients
um an action potential uh just
just to explain an action potential with
basically a nerve impulse
so that's when you know you get your um
signal from a nerve cell to make another
cell do something as
an action potential and the duration of
an action potential
uh it can be as low as one millisecond
so we're dealing with incredibly fast
events voltage imaging can be used to
directly measure the action potential
so that means you need to perform it
incredibly quickly and you'll typically
be performing voltage imaging at over
500 frames per second
one of the other parts of it is calcium
sparks
and calcium transients now these are
these are both parts of
cardiac cells and
calcium sparks are small events that
occur in cardiac cells
that are often the precursor to a larger
calcium transient
which is where the intracellular calcium
concentration rises considerably
to result in a muscle contraction
and you can see here the calcium spark
is typically less than about 40
milliseconds in duration
so that's an incredibly fast event and a
calcium transient or the calcium
transient
can have a time to peak so that's
basically from your point of
low calcium to maximum calcium
saturation in the cell
of 20 milliseconds or less so again an
incredibly fast
event and you want to record calcium
sparks and transients at a much faster
rate than this to
to accurately measure calcium release um
and transient amplitudes which means
typically imaging over
a thousand frames per second or one
kilohertz um
an important thing though to remember
with these techniques is that
you need the speed in combination with a
larger field of view
typically um and that's to to maximize
the amount of data captured and you know
to allow imaging of entire neural
circuits for example
but of course the classic method for for
increasing frame rate
was to make a smaller region which was a
compromise that needed to be made
because the speed was the most important
thing
and this is why we've been seeing a lot
of interest in the kinetics in this
application
field in particular because the speed
can be achieved
or even exceeded in a much larger area
a lot much larger field of view than
than used to be possible
the other thing about high speed is high
speed requires low exposure times
so that means less signal coming from
the sample and that's where the back
illuminated 95
quantum efficiency and low read noise
come in to make sure that when we are
imaging fast
we can still detect our sample and
acquire images capable of the the
quantitative data analysis that needs to
be done afterwards
so the next application i want to talk
about is light sheet microscopy
so again to give a short introduction
and light sheet microscopy uses a sheet
of light to illuminate a single plane
of a sample which is then scanned
through the sample
to form a three-dimensional image it's
incredibly
kind to samples one of the key features
of light sheet microscopy
is that um your chances of photo damage
are extremely low you can image samples
for
long long amounts of time
which makes it unique as a technique
what it also does it allows you to image
in three dimensions
and so that means that the light sheet
requires speed
for a slightly different reason to
calcium and voltage imaging and that's
because we're adding that extra
dimension
um so because most light sheet is
performed to give you a
a three-dimensional image we're no
longer dealing with just x and y
we've added z and that's because you
know imaging fast in three dimensions
lets us see the whole biological system
rather than just a single plane
but of course it requires speed because
because it's capable of both very large
and extremely fast image collection
and some modalities of light sheet are
only limited by the speed of the camera
the image that you can see there on the
right for example
that is a maximum intensity projection
of a of a cleared mouse brain
now this is a huge sample you can see
from the scale by that this is
this is about an 11 millimeter by 11
millimeter
sample we're looking at here it was
acquired i think on um
like a 1.2 x objective
and this was 500 microns deep as well as
this 11 by 11 millimeter
x and y and the total time it took to
acquire this image
and this huge image with a with quite a
thick sample
was eight minutes and
i i don't i don't have the figures but
if you were to do that
on say a point scanning confocal
you would be waiting a lot longer than
eight minutes so
it's an incredibly fast technique and
the
the one of the big points about speed
with it is that you get to do this
this section these these z stacks so you
can build up a three-dimensional image
and that's one of the things you need
the
the speed for
um and of course the reason that we that
we want to watch these things that we
want to image these things is because
you know and living things are dynamic
and ever-changing so the faster we can
image them and the deeper that we can
image them
the more of these processes we can see
which is why we're seeing a lot of light
she
more and more light sheep being done
faster and bigger
to see more um and look at these dynamic
processes
now there's another type of light sheet
another modality that i'd like to
discuss which is interesting because it
puts it
it pulls in another type of speed as
well and that's digitally scanned light
sheet
and this is a modality where um you
synchronize the sweep of the light sheet
with the rolling shutter of an scmos
camera
and this is this is interesting because
it's challenging to do at speed
and that's because you're usually
limited to a single direction
if you can imagine it you've got your
light sheet on this example here on the
right
coming down so your light sheet is going
down through the sample and at the same
time
your rolling shutter of your cmos camera
is going
down through the sample at the same time
so you end up with um
the beam waist uh being in focus
and the beam shoulders being then um out
of focus
and so you only get that very high
contrast image from that
in focus region which is great because
you get a very high contrast image of
you know of very big samples
but this is where speed comes in again
because
speed can limit your data collection in
this kind of a mode because
if you can imagine a typical camera
working the the role
of the of the cmos shutter only goes in
one direction
um let's say in this case it goes top to
bottom
so when you're when you're sweeping your
light sheet through your sample
um you go top to bottom and you you know
you you synchronize it with the role of
the cmos camera
but then you need to reset it to the top
of it to the top again to then
roll down again with the camera and
that's slow
because you're stopping your data
acquisition to roll again
so with programmable scan mode on the
kinetics
we actually made it so that you can scan
down and you could also scan up and you
can also
alternate so you can scan down then up
then down then
up and in that way you increase your
speed massively
for this mode because you no longer have
to reset it back to the top again
so again not a not what you typically
think of when when you think of speed
but nevertheless
it increases the speed of of what it is
you're trying to do
and to show you what this looks like
i've created a pretty
simple powerpoint animation so if you
imagine here that the
the sample is the blue triangle there
as we sweep the sensor down um the
triangle arrives at the camera in the
right orientation and his output as such
then when we sweep up the sensor the
triangle arrives at the camera the wrong
way round
but with our for example scan mode
implementation the camera
outputs the image in the right
orientation so every image
is perfectly aligned
so the last application that i want to
talk about is high content imaging
any kind of imaging could be high
content this isn't you know
like a specific application uh if the
objective is to obtain as much data as
feasibly possible regardless of the
imaging system the sample and the
magnification or the fluorophore
as long as the main aim is to maximize
data capture
you're probably doing high content
imaging um this is often done with
multi-world plates so like a 96 well
plate so you can image lots of samples
one after another extremely quickly
and sometimes do multiple dimensions and
multiple channels so yeah
it's most useful for these high
throughput applications
so you can maximize the data collection
for a better statistical analysis so
you've got examples such as in drug
discovery
imaging dense tissue with high mag
stitching
and lab on a chip imaging which is also
pretty interesting so like the other
applications i've spoken about
we want to go fast we want x
y and z dimensional in uh information
here you do want to get
that depth information in your samples
as well um
but you also want to add potentially
multiple channels like in the
multi-color fluorescence image you can
see on the right here
so we then have the time required um
with with uh say you're using a multiple
plate you then have the time required to
move to the next well
as well and to take your next set of
images so speed really in this case
means
minimizing downtime so it's another
definition of speed but also an
incredibly important one
because with high content imaging with
so much data that you want to acquire
the faster and the larger the amount of
data that can be captured the better
so a high frame rate is a given because
you can capture your x y and z
information faster but a large large
field of view is also important because
you can maximize the amount of data
acquired in a single acquisition
so you you know you don't want to waste
time
acquiring extra images to tile and
stitch if you don't have to
and that's where the kinetics can make a
big difference to efficiency and
throughput
in high content imaging
so to summarize what we've presented in
this webinar today
high speed imaging it's a multi-faceted
challenge and it will always involve
some amount of compromise and and in
many applications
speed alone is never the only concern
and as we just saw different
applications need speed for different
reasons
and there will always almost always be
an additional benefit
and whether that's the additional field
of view that's needed or the sensitivity
that's needed or the resolution that's
needed
it's very rare that speed is needed in a
vacuum
and when we created the kinetics
we created it specifically to address
these challenges with the unique
combination of specifications
that feature the extremely high frame
rate the massive field of view
and the back illuminated low read noise
sensitivity and
on top of that the ability to use the
three different modes on the camera
to further optimize based on
experimental requirements
so thank you very much from both me
and ratchet we're going to be around for
the next 10 minutes or so to take
questions
so again thank you and please ask away
okay some of those questions are rolling
in um
i guess we can get uh dan do you want to
just kind of go through the questions
and we can
kind of answer them as we go uh yeah
absolutely
um so yeah let's start with
a couple of quick ones just to get
um get some quick answers for you guys
um
what is the size of the camera pixels
and the kinetics has 6.5 by 6.5 micron
pixels
um another quick one um for you ratchet
where is the data stored on the camera
or streamed
uh it is streamed straight to the pc
um another one uh when we have
on the micromanager software actually
it's a micromanager is a free software
to control your camera
and does this software also allow you to
do tile and stitch operations
uh now i believe that it does ratchet um
do you have uh
other information i've i've definitely
seen thailand stitch applications been
done with um
using micromanager before um i don't
know the exact
uh way you'd have to do it without a
little bit of reading um
but i'm pretty sure i have seen it uh
ratchet yeah as long as you
as long as you have the the the hardware
that goes into micromanager that will
allow you to do that tile and stitching
as well
then then yes it should allow you to do
that
perfect um so a bit of um
a bit more of a complex question which
i'm
also going to send your way ratchet um
does
so so an 8-bit mode does an 8-bit mode
have enough
dynamic range for for for real imaging
uh i think the short answer is yes but
it it also depends
on um you know how the quantification
happens so if you take you know if we
keep in mind
eight bits is roughly you know 256
different
intensities of light there uh you want
to be able to have enough
intensity resolution so it's not that
each one of those intensity levels
is a extremely large number an extremely
large amount of signal
and so there is a bit of a trade-off
there with the maximum amount of signal
that you're able to measure
is reduced but i think in terms of does
it have enough dynamic range
yes plus if you're using the 8-bit mode
you're going
extremely fast so the amount of flight
you would have per frame is
is also reduced yeah
exactly and i've seen the same thing
when i've been out in labs with the
camera
myself it's when you're going extremely
fast obviously your exposure times are
low the amount of light you're acquiring
is low
um so you're only actually using that
very bottom
end of the um of the dynamic range
anyway which is perfectly within
the realm of of where we have our 8-bit
mode um
so yeah it has been used successfully
quantitatively as well
another quick one and how compatible
with kinetics with
labview packages that's one for you
ratchet
uh it's compatible we have a telden
photometrics labview adapter on our
website that
you can go download now it's freely
available
so it should be should be fully uh you
know useful
usable in labview perfect
um so an application specific question
here
um so in terms of single molecule
imaging at high speeds what is the most
important
or limiting factor in modern scmos
cameras
um for example is it read noise quantum
efficiency pixel size
um that's a really great question um
because
it's entirely dependent on
on the application um as with as with
all these things
whenever i visit um a lab with the
camera it's always okay
so you're doing this but what exactly
specifically are you doing
um you know for some people uh doing
single molecule imaging their the field
of view is very important because they
want to maximize the number of molecules
they're looking at
and for some they don't care about field
of view at all and they'll happily
shrink right down to look at say a
strand of dna that they want to look at
individual fluorophores landing on and
in which case they can go super small
and then they can boost their
uh their frame rates right up in that
way um
generally speaking what i what i always
see with single molecule imaging
is um it is low photon count
um is very low signals so generally
speaking
um what we've seen to make the biggest
difference
in terms of single molecule imaging is
particularly with
the prime95b scmos camera which is
another one of our cameras
has been increasing sensitivity through
the 95
quantum efficiency the back illuminated
sensor but also the larger pixel size
as this was typically done with emc
cameras in the past
um which had a larger pixel and the fact
that the prime95v has a larger pixel and
is a back illuminated cmos
we often found made one of the biggest
differences for single molecule imaging
and caused
um most people we've visited to change
from emc ccd to scmos and to take
advantage of the larger field of view or
the larger speed
or the increased resolution
another one for you ratchet uh so how do
you handle the field of view limitations
of microscope optics
uh so what i would say is uh the the
microscope
that dan was using today is a nikon ti2
which
the the optics on that stand have
allowed us to use the full
field of view of the of the kinetics
camera
but otherwise i would say that having
the ability to region down
and still have significantly improved
frame rates over
you know those typical scmos cameras is
a pretty good advantage there
it's always a little bit more helpful to
have more area than you need and
to be able to reduce it than have the
opposite problem of not having enough
area
yeah absolutely so what
what mount does the camera come with
then to access the full sensor size
so the camera comes with uh it comes
with an f-mount
but the way that we've designed the
camera the mounts are actually swappable
so you're able to remove that f-mount
and
screw on a t-mount which is just a you
know a very large c-mount if you will
and then if you if you have a microscope
stand that doesn't necessarily have an
f-mount or t-mount
compatible adapter it does also come
with a c-mount front which you can then
use
um on the kinetics you know with with
the with the
with the condition that you know you'll
have to reduce the the effective field
of view down to you know 22 millimeters
at the most
god thanks ratchet um so last question
i'm i'm afraid we're
um short of time so it's just one more
question i'll be able to answer but
um yeah i will make sure to follow up
with everyone who has
asked questions myself and ratchet will
send you an email
with answers to your questions after the
broadcast don't worry your questions
will be answered
um the last one that i just want to
address in is where can i get
information about these cameras um you
can get information about all of our
cameras
on our website photometrics.com if you
go to the products drop down at the top
you'll see the kinetics right at the top
of it that will give you
a full breakdown of all the
specifications
applications information and you know
other cool stuff in there you can use
like a a calculator that we've got that
lets you set for example
a speed that you would like to achieve
and it will tell you the region size
that you should be using for that
and the other way around if you set a
region size it will tell you the speed
so some cool resources on there but if
you just go to
your product section our website you can
find out even more about this camera
and our others so thank you again
everyone for attending um i will follow
up with the rest of you who have asked
questions
after the broadcast um ratchet do you
want to
sign off as well yeah absolutely thank
you thank you all for taking the time to
to attend and uh you know glad that
we're glad that you could be here and
hopefully hopefully this was
helpful and you know the the kinetics is
something that
that is interesting to you
cool thank you everyone thank you
everyone thanks everyone
you